If you already made a decision to become an
entrepreneur but you don't know what to do
next, today, in this video, I will give you
a five-step process for you to become an entrepreneur,
the evolution of becoming an entrepreneur,
and you can make a decision for yourself on
which route you want to go to.
So before I get into the five-steps, let me
first talk to you about different industries,
sectors, routes, services you can take to
becoming an entrepreneur.
Because the great thing about wanting to become
an entrepreneur is not one dimensional.
There are multi-dimensions of becoming an
entrepreneur and I'll share with you which
route I took, but there's many routes.
So as I go through all of these here with
you, you need to ask yourself what sparks.
You may be a 17-year-old watching this and
say boom!
That sparks with me.
Or make a list of three.
Then investigate those three and choose one
of the routes and give 10 years to it.
So now, you may be a 32-year-old and you're
saying, "I already made a decision which route
I'm going to.
But how do I make a decision to take it to
the next level."
I may talk about that at the end of this video.
So first, let's start off with the top left.
Financial.
This is the route I took.
I started off with different ones, but this
is what I connected with the most.
Now for you, financial could be many different
things.
It could be somebody selling memorabilia.
I know somebody who sells hundred thousand
dollar baseball cards or more.
That's what they do.
They just sold one card for $1.15 million.
It was a Mickey Mantle 1952 tops baseball
card, PSA, I think it was 9 that sold for
$1.15 or PSA 8 that sold for that much money.
That's memorabilia.
Maybe art is financial.
Insurance.
Stocks.
Real Estate.
Artwork.
Whatever it is, that's all part of financial.
FOREX, commodities, that's financial.
Then you have consulting.
You could be somebody that helps with strategy.
We're going to come and help your business
put a strategy together, take it to the next
level.
Lawyers, you're still consulting.
IT consulting.
Marketing, advertising, CPA.
That's all part of consulting.
Services could be you're a personal trainer,
car wash, Uber, cleaning pools, haircuts.
That's service, because I can cut my hair
myself, but maybe I'm not going to do as good
of a job as you are.
You're an expert.
I come to you and I pay $20, in exchange for
you to do it as an expert, because I don't
want to do it so I'll give it to you.
That is an exchange for service that you're
providing.
Hospitality could be a restaurant.
Hotel, bar, nightclub.
You may say, man, I just love bars, I grew
up in it with my family.
I want to go and find a way to make a real
cool bar and that's what I want to do.
Restaurant.
My mother's got this most incredible recipe
and what if we can turn it into a business,
right?
Inventor - it could be research and development.
It could be technology.
You can invent the next table that turns around
into a whole different thing and you turn
it around and the color changes.
All these other things you can do as an inventor.
Then you have nutrition, which is health and
fitness.
You can take the nutrition route, the gym
route, the medical route.
You may like that.
You may go want to find the cure for cancer.
You may want to go out there and open up a
gym and what makes your gym very cool is it's
a gym combined with a library.
And hey, matter of fact, that may be an incredible
idea right there for you to be thinking about.
I'm going to open up a gym and I'm going to
add a bookstore to it.
Can you imagine you're buying books on this
side, then I'm going to go lift weights.
So after my workout, I have a smoothie or
something and there's books I want to buy,
and next thing you know I'm buying two or
three books.
That's your niche.
You want to do gym and something else at the
same time.
Manufacturing.
Cars, computers, clothing.
You like clothes.
You want to go a certain brand.
Expertise.
Language.
You speak multiple different languages.
You want to take that to the next level.
Electrical, plumbing, software, coding, fashion.
You see fashion in a different way where people
look at you and you just know how to put it
together.
Then you have entertainment.
Entertainment could be graphic design, movies,
dancing, editing, music, writing, acting,
makeup.
You're just all about entertainment.
And that's fascinating to you.
Agriculture could be farm, equipment, natural
resources, oil.
Obviously, some of these things connect with
other ones that we have here.
But you can pretty much choose.
By the way, there's some that I'm not even
putting here on the board, because we would
need a ten times the size of this board to
have it on here.
But you get to pick and choose which one you
want to go with.
For me, one of the things I notice happens
a lot is the newness mentality, which is a
big mistake for some veteran entrepreneurs,
which means what?
They made a decision to be in one.
They've been in it for five to ten years,
and all of a sudden they say, no, I want to
try this.
No, I want to try this.
No, I want to try this, thinking that's the
real issue or the challenge.
But you got to choose one and stick to it
for ten years.
So now, let's just say you watch this.
And you say, okay.
How to become an entrepreneur.
I connect with this [financial], I connect
with this [consulting], I connect with this
[services].
Great, what do I do next?
Five steps.
Choose one route.
One route.
Two, go find a place to work, for, you're
not an entrepreneur yet.
But go find a place to work for and learn
from somebody that knows exactly what they're
doing.
Three, become an expert at that one thing.
So, for instance.
You go into insurance, you learn under a company,
let's just say you got a job, you're working
under Northwestern Mutual.
I'm just throwing a name out there.
Then from there, you decide to go somewhere
where you learn under a great producer and
you learn how to do all this stuff that he's
learning.
And then you become an expert at insurance.
You go work in a hotel, a restaurant, and
you work from the bottom.
You become a busboy and then you become a
hostess, and a waiter.
Then you become a restaurant manager.
Then you move up in the restaurant and you
say, man, this is exciting.
I want to run a restaurant within a very massive
chain.
I want to go to Europe and do all this other
stuff.
Whatever it is.
Step #1, choose a route.
#2, work for somebody that knows what they're
doing and work your way up, #3, become an
expert.
Four, find a way or two to make it better.
Find a way or two to make it better.
So, you're going to write things down and
say, "I would do it much better if we did
it this way."
Once you find a way to make it better, then
become a leader, either in the company you're
part of where you have a voice, and ask to
own a piece of the company, or earn to have
a piece of the company, or two, if they say
no, leave, and go to another place where you
can own a piece of the company or become an
entrepreneur.
That's the route, you can pick and choose
how to get to that route, very simple.
Choose a route, work under somebody you can
learn from them, become an expert, make a
list of how you would do it better, next become
a voice and a leader, ask to own a piece,
earn a piece.
If that doesn't work, go to another place
where you can or start it yourself and become
the entrepreneur.
Especially throughout the entire time, because
I get a lot of people that tell me things
like, Hey Pat, I have this great idea.
And what do I do with this great idea I have
with the company.
Because I want to become an entrepreneur,
but I don't have any money.
So how do I become an entrepreneur?
Almost every entrepreneur I know worked somewhere,
made some money, saved the money, then they
started a business.
That's how it works.
It's not just I've never ran a business before,
I've never had a job before, I've never done
anything before, can you please give me a
half a million dollars.
There's an evolution you've got to get through
to becoming an entrepreneur.
Now obviously, there are many different routes,
just like a relationship.
You can meet somebody and you marry them out
of church.
Somebody else meets them on Tinder.
Somebody else meets them online.
Somebody meets them on Facebook.
Somebody meets them at a party.
Somebody meets them at bar.
There are as many different routes that you
can, but when it comes to entrepreneurship,
this step that I told you the five steps happen
to be the most common way for you to become
an entrepreneur.
And eventually build a business, become successful,
and make a ton of money for yourself, and
have fun doing it.
So, with that being said, Paul, why don't
we throw the pillow out here.
I think I forgot one other point, right?
I think I forgot one other point to add.
On my top left, your top right, there's three
ways you can sell these products.
One is face-to-face, then I think it's online,
then I think it's phone calls.
Should be right up here.
Yes, face-to-face, online, phone call.
You will pretty much figure out how you can
sell these products.
You can sell face-to-face.
I'm going to come sit in front of you and
sell it to you.
I'm going to sell this product online.
Or I'm going to sell this product through
phone.
Whatever way it is, you try to find a way
to do it better.
Anyways, you got any questions about this,
comment on the bottom.
If you have not subscribed, Paul. . . this
is an older pillow, Pauley.
We got a new pillow we. . . you know what,
Paul, why don't we do this.
Why don't we do this a little bit different.
Show me - we picked that one, right?
Give me three of them, give me the top three.
Here's one that we like [laughter - they're
so funny].
We have to record what Paul just did.
Only Paul would spill something like this,
just turn it around.
Mario, I hope you see this because Mario always
gives Paul a hard time.
[Is that water?]
That is not water, it's a protein shake.
[Oh no!]
Paul, he's got to do things like that.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go, here we go.
Okay, so this here is from Sara Shabana, which,
by the way, this is probably the most.
. the quality, Sara, I got to give you some
love here.
This pillow's amazing.
This is from Sara Shabana, it was in the top
three.
Then we have one from Billy Wilson, which
we love, Billy Wilson's.
Let's put a picture of Billy Wilson, the bird
he gave to Kansas State when he dropped out
and USA Today and Huffington Post, everybody
wrote a story about him, and he said, I dropped
out after watching a video, Stay in School
or Dropout on Valuetainment.
This is from Billy Wilson.
Billy, cannot wait to see you rock it in the
world of entrepreneurship.
You got the fire to pull it off.
I'm looking forward to hearing your success
story.
This is from Billy.
But we didn't choose it as first place.
First place goes to this one here, Jennifer
Mac's pillow, Valuetainment, one million
subscribers is the goal, Jen Mac, thank you
for this pillow and for the rest of you that
are watching, we have a lot of other pillows
that we got here, but these were the top three.
If you haven't subscribed to this channel,
please do so.
If you got any questions about this, you can
Snap me, but when you Snap me, please do it
through video, not just text.
Do it through video, because it's easier for
me to respond back.
And don't do a 50-part video.
Do one or two videos that you put so I can
get back to you at times when I'm able to
check it.
And my Snap code should be on the video at
the bottom, your bottom left, I think it's
over here, right?
It's over here.
Click on this to follow me.
User name is betdavid19.
But this is the pillow we will be using in
all of 2017 and Paul, you got to make sure
you clean up all that protein that you're
making a mess with.
Here - oh my gosh, this is nonstop with Paul,
man.
Hey, take care everybody, bye bye.